it's no secret that America's
infrastructure is crumbling we have more
than 600,000 bridges and almost 70,000
of those desperately need repairs this
is a this is a major catastrophe for the
state just as far as infrastructure as
we look here it does appear that it's
this one section between two pilings
with emergency flashers on that orange
car is still hanging onto the side of
that bridge to secure the future of our
infrastructure we must have timely and
effective inspections but currently in
sections involved costly teams of divers
performing time-consuming often
dangerous and always tedious work maybe
there's a better way
oh hello it's a quiet morning in Fort
Lauderdale and there isn't much in the
water besides mangroves and the
occasional fishing boat
today a group of florida atlantic
university engineers are putting
something new in the canal a team of
autonomous vehicles self piloted boats
that can not only navigate through the
water but work with each other carl von
ellen reader has been working on
autonomous boats for 25 years and today
he's demonstrating how his machine
learning programs can be used for bridge
inspection tell me a little bit about
the experiment that you're conducting
right here what we're doing is we have a
team of unmanned surface vehicles that's
working together with a bridge inspector
to essentially look at the condition of
the underwater structure of the bridge
one of the vehicles has an underwater
acoustic imaging system that basically
is looking at the underwater structure
physically there's a computer on board
that takes in information from the
sensors and makes decisions so rather
than sort of pre programming them to
handle scenario in a very specific way
programming them to follow behavioral
responses instead they can actually
handle a wider range of scenarios
behavioral learning means these boats
are able to act on very general commands
but the details like the fastest way to
image these bridge columns they work out
on their own the robots are going to
work with a bridge inspector I presume
the bridge inspector is not a robot no
bridge inspector is a person okay and a
person's basically watching the progress
of the inspection on a monitor remotely
on the land here and basically if
anything looks like it could be a
problem then the inspector can redirect
the USV team to go back and have a
closer look at it at which point then
you might want to dispatch divers but
now you know that you're looking for
something specific you're not just sort
of sending them out at random well
absolutely some of the bridges here in
Florida there several miles long you're
looking at dozens and dozens of columns
it becomes quite tedious and quite easy
for someone to making the state
unmanned systems can perform monotonous
repetitive tasks that a human operator
might find very difficult to sustain for
a long period of time putting them
together in a team with human operators
where human operator can maybe focus on
on higher level things and let the the
vehicle do low-level things such as
control itself and make basic decisions
about where it should go can be
extremely helpful improving the safety
of our infrastructure isn't the only
application for carl's autonomous
technology it could have huge effects on
shipping construction and search and
rescue but it also points to a changing
paradigm of how we will work alongside
machines as robots and computers become
more capable our traditional divisions
of labor are evolving allowing humans
and robots to each focus on what they do
best
you